supongamos que deseamos obtener un valor
aproximado de la raíz cuadrada de 4.36
queremos obtener un valor aproximado de
esto y no tenemos una calculadora a la
mano como hacemos esto bien una manera
es sabemos que la raíz cuadrada de 4 es
2 la raíz cuadrada principal de 4 es
igual a 2 así es que la raíz cuadrada de
4.36 va a ser ligeramente mayor a 2 pero
cómo le hacemos para precisar eso eso es
lo que te voy a enseñar en este vídeo un
método para aproximar una función cerca
de un valor que es conocido de que estoy
hablando bien supongamos que tenemos la
función que tenemos la función fx igual
a la raíz cuadrada de x que por supuesto
es igual a x elevada a la un medio
sabemos cuánto es f 2 sabemos que f 2
ese perdón no es efe de 2 es efe de 4
sabemos que f de 4 es igual a 2
principal de 4 es igual a 2 y lo que
queremos aproximar lo que queremos
calcular es el valor de f en 4.36 esta
es otra manera de plantear exactamente
la misma pregunta con la que iniciamos
el vídeo visualicemos la función
construyamos nuestros ejes aquí tenemos
el eje y este es el eje y y aquí tenemos
lg
x y voy a hacer la gráfica de igual a fx
la gráfica de ye igual a fx es más o
menos así
no está mal no está mal mi gráfica
esta es la gráfica de ye igual a fx
sabemos que f de 4 es igual a 2
efe de 4 más o menos por aquí tenemos 4
esto es igual a 2 no lo hice a escala
este sería 2 y lo que queremos aproximar
es el valor de f en 4.36 y aquí tenemos
4.36 más o menos
efe de 4.36 sería más o menos por aquí
este es el valor que queremos aproximar
efe de 4.36 insisto insisto no tenemos
una calculadora la mano entonces como
hacemos esto usando lo que ya sabemos de
la derivada que tal si calculamos la
ecuación de la recta tangente a este
punto que tenemos aquí la ecuación de la
recta tangente en x igual a 4 y usamos
esa línea lización para aproximar
localmente para aproximar valores
cercanos a ese punto
esta técnica se llama lineal y estación
local lo que estoy diciendo es
calculemos la ecuación de esta recta
llamémosle l
después usamos esa recta es decir
evaluamos l en 4.36 lo cual esperamos
que sea más fácil de evaluar que esto
que tenemos aquí y como hacemos esto una
manera de hacerlo y obviamente hay
varias maneras de encontrar la ecuación
de una recta una manera va a ser
entonces considerar que l de x l de x va
a ser igual a efe de 4 va a ser igual a
efe de 4 que es 2 más la pendiente la
pendiente de la recta tangente cuando x
vale 4 que por supuesto es f prima
evaluado en 4 es la pendiente de esta
recta de l de x
efe prima de 4 déjame escribir eso aquí
esta de aquí es la pendiente en x igual
a 4 la pendiente de esta recta tangente
así es que el valor de cualquier otro
punto va a ser f de 4 + la pendiente que
multiplica a qué tan lejos se encuentre
ese punto de 4 así es que va a ser por x
menos 4
veamos si esto hace sentido si
sustituimos 4.36 aquí si sustituimos
4.36 de hecho déjame hacer un
acercamiento a la gráfica para que nos
demos cuenta que está sucediendo así es
que si este si este es un acercamiento y
estoy haciendo un acercamiento de esta
región que tenemos aquí así es que este
es el punto 4
efe de 4 y vamos a graficar l de x
vamos a graficar el dx esta es el dx y
digamos
que este punto de aquí digamos que este
punto de aquí es 4.36
efe de 4.36 y ese valor de f lo vamos a
aproximar a través de la recta a través
de l es decir lo vamos a aproximar con
el valor que obtenemos a través de la
recta donde este punto va a ser
este punto va a ser 4.36 como el de 4.36
que se está funciona evaluada cuando x
es igual a 4.36 y cuánto es esto
veámoslo hagamos el cálculo esto es
efe de 4 efe de 4 que es 2 más
efe prima de 4 la pendiente de la recta
que es f prima de 4 que multiplica a
4.36 menos 4 4.36 menos 4 esto es 0.36 y
eso hace sentido en piezas en 2 y
obtienes que tu cambio en x es 0.36 así
es que tu cambio en que va a ser la
pendiente que multiplica al cambio en x
y eso te lleva a ese punto calculemos
entonces calculemos entonces cuál es el
valor que corresponde a esta expresión
para esto necesitamos calcular f prima
de 4 vayamos un poco arriba
pero quiero dejar esta visualización
aquí tenemos entonces que f prima de x
es igual a un medio por x elevada a la
menos un medio y aquí estoy usando la
regla de potencias así que f prima de 4
es igual a un medio que multiplica a 4
elevado a la menos un medio y esto es
igual a un medio que multiplica a un
medio 4 al a un medio es 24 a la menos
un medio es un medio y un medio por un
medio es igual a un cuarto así es que el
de 4.36 y aquí nos merecemos unas
fanfarrias l de 4.36 es igual a efe de 4
que es déjame reescribir todo efe de 4
más más voy a usar el mismo amarillo que
tenemos acá arriba
efe de 4 más efe prima de 4 que
multiplica a
que multiplica a
4.36 4.36 deja de poner lo mejor todo
con este color
con este nuevo color voy a poner el 4.36
4.36 menos menos cuatro menos cuatro de
hecho voy a marcar los cuatros con el
mismo color para que podamos
identificarlos visualmente y esto que es
igual
efe de 4 ya vimos que es 2
efe prima de 4 también ya calculamos que
es igual a un cuarto está aquí es igual
a un cuarto 4.36 menos 4 es igual a 0.36
y esto es igual a 2 más un cuarto por
0.36 esto es 0.09 y esto esto es igual a
2.09 esa es nuestra aproximación y de
acuerdo a como lo dibujamos aquí esta
aproximación es un valor que es
ligeramente mayor a la raíz cuadrada de
4.36 esto lo podemos escribir acá arriba
esto es aproximadamente igual a no mejor
vamos a ponerlo de la siguiente manera
voy a escribirlo aquí abajo la raíz
cuadrada de 4.36 que es igual a efe de
4.36 es aproximadamente igual a 2.09
ahora supongamos que apareció en esta
calculadora y nos da curiosidad saber
qué tan buena es nuestra aproximación
aparece
entonces nuestra calculadora y queremos
obtener el valor de la raíz cuadrada de
4.36 y obtenemos que es igual a 2.0 88
la aproximación que obtuvimos coincide
con el valor real a nivel de centésimas
es una muy buena aproximación y como
pudimos vislumbrar aquí a partir de
nuestra gráfica nuestra aproximación es
de hecho ligeramente mayor que el valor
real